Praise be to Allah, and peace and blessings be upon the Messenger of Allah, his family, his
companions, and those who follow his guidance.
Imam Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him, said: Chapter: The Saying of Allah, the Exalted: “Do they
not think that they will be
resurrected on a great Day, the Day when mankind will stand before the Lord of
the worlds?”
Ibn Abbas said: “And their means
will be cut off.” He
said: “The means of connection
in this world.”
Yes. In the name of Allah, and praise be to Allah, and peace
and blessings be upon the Messenger of Allah, his family, and all his companions.
Imam
Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him, said: “Do
they not think that they will be resurrected on a great Day, the Day when mankind will stand before the Lord of the worlds?” Ibn Abbas, may Allah be pleased
with him, said:
This verse is proof of
the Resurrection and the obligation to believe in it, and that
all that they connected with in this world will be cut off, and no
righteous hope will remain.
Sheikh Khalid Al-Dhafeeri, may Allah have mercy on him, said: This .... He
mentioned the hadith of Ibn Umar on the authority of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, regarding the
Day when mankind will stand before the Lord of the worlds.
He said: “One of them will stand in his sweat, meaning his perspiration up to his ears.”
Imam Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him, said:
Umar, may God be pleased with him, may
God bless him and grant him peace,
all
day. And all of this is due
to his deeds in this world,
because the sweat,
as will come in the hadith, will
sink seventy cubits into the earth,
because the sun will be close to the people, and each will be according to
his deeds. Some of them will have their
sweat reach up to their ankles, some will have it reach up
to their knees, some will be bridled by the
Arabs of the mosque,
and some will be under the shade of the Throne of the Most Merciful, under the shade of
His charity. This is
God’s will.
Alltions
will cause them to drown in sweat, because we find that the sun will
be close to the
people on that day, and from mankind,
those who will drown in their sweat, or
their sweat will reach up to their
ankles.  And from them are those whose
sweat will reach up to their
shoulders.  And from them are those who
will be completely submerged in their
sweat.  And from them are those who are
under the shade of Allah.   All of this is to
warn people of the horror of the situation so that
they may act with the means of salvation.
He mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: “
People will sweat on the Day of Resurrection
until their sweat sinks seventy cubits into the earth, and it will
reach their ears.” May
God have mercy on him. Imam Bukhari, may
God be pleased with him, may God’s peace and blessings be upon him. [
Music]
[Music]
Then he mentioned:
Chapter on Retribution on the Day of Resurrection,
which is Al-Haqqah,
because it contains the
reward
and the realities of the matter. Al-Haqqah is
one, and Al-Qari’ah, Al-Ghashiyah, As-Sakhkhah, and At-Taghabun.
The loss of the people of Paradise over the people of Hell. These are all
names of the Day of Resurrection.
Al-Qurtubi, may God have mercy on him, brought them to more than
80 names.
The Imam, may God have mercy on him,
[Music]
Day of Resurrection. [
Music]
will
[Music] Al-Haqqah, the truth, and
Al-Haqud
[Applause] Al-Qari’ah, Al-Ghashiyah, As-Sakhkhah, At-
Taghabun.
He mentioned the hadith of Abdullah, who
said: The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: “The first thing to be judged
between people will be bloodshed.”
This contains the enormity of the matter of bloodshed and the prohibition of
killing a Muslim, as
it is one of the greatest major sins.
The Imam, may God have mercy on him,
Abdullah, may God be pleased with him, may God’s peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
And the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, mentions
that the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: “
Whoever has wronged his brother should seek his forgiveness
before his death, for there will be no dinar or dirham there. He should seek forgiveness in this life before some of his
good deeds are taken and given to
his brother. If he has no good deeds, some of his brother’s bad deeds will be taken and placed upon him.” Imam
Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, narrated that
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, said: “Whoever has wronged his brother should seek his forgiveness before his death, for there will be no dinar or dirham there. He should seek
forgiveness in this life before some of his good deeds are taken and given to his brother, or if he has no good deeds, some of his brother’s bad deeds will be taken and placed upon him.” This indicates the prohibition of injustice, especially injustice against a brother, or someone with whom you have a relationship, or Muslims in general. It is obligatory for a person to seek forgiveness for it by asking for forgiveness
and returning rights to their owners. Praise be to
God.  Abu
Saeed al-Khudri
said: The Messenger of Allah, may God bless him and grant him peace, said:
The believers will be saved from Hellfire and detained on a bridge
between Paradise and Hellfire. This
bridge
will be after the Sirat (the bridge over Hell), because he said: The believers will be saved
from Hellfire, meaning after the Sirat. It was also said that the bridge
is the end of the Sirat that is next to
Paradise.
This is the place where those who were
saved from Hellfire will gather. This purification will be granted to them
before the mercy of God Almighty,
Abu Saeed al-Khudri, may God be pleased with him. The Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: The
bridge [
music]
[music]
He said:
They will be told about the injustices that were between them in
the world until they are cleansed and purified, meaning they will be freed
from these
sins. They will
enter Paradise. Permission will be granted to them to enter Paradise. By the One in Whose
Hand is the soul of Muhammad, one of them will be more familiar with his place in Paradise than he was with his place in
the world, because he will not be lost. The
first thing he does when he enters Paradise is know his place more clearly than he
knew his place in the world. The Prophet, may
God bless him and grant him peace,
[music]
will be given permission to seek the right from the right.
Cleansed
and purified by way of retaliation and
retribution, they will be admitted into Paradise. And
he said, "By Him in hand is
the Muhammad
[music]."
This is as the Almighty said, "Those who believe and do
righteous deeds -
their Lord will guide them because of their faith. Rivers will flow beneath them." Here, guidance is their guidance to Paradise, their guidance to their homes. The Almighty, the Exalted, the Majestic, the Most High ...
The demand for the great
and the small, all deeds are accounted for, and forgiveness is not granted.
[Music]
takas
As for the reckoning of the presentation, this is for the people of faith. Their
deeds are presented to them, and
then they recognize God's favor upon them when He concealed them in
this world and forgave them for them in the Hereafter.
May
God Almighty hasten it.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Aisha, which is like the previous hadith, may
God have mercy on him. The hadith of Aisha, may God be pleased with her, and he
mentioned the hadith of Anas, may God be pleased with him, that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: The disbeliever will be brought on
the Day of Resurrection, and it will be said to him: If you had the
earth full of gold, would you ransom yourself with it? He will say: Yes. He will say to him: I have been
asked for something easier than that. May
God have mercy on him. The hadith of Anas, may God be pleased with him. May
God, peace and blessings be upon him, say:
This will
not be accepted from any of them, even if they ransom themselves with the earth full of gold. And something
easier than that is explained by the other narration. The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: I wanted from you something
easier than this while you were in the loins of Adam: that you not associate
anything with Me, but you refused except to associate others with Me.
[Music]
Mention of the hadith of Adi ibn Hamm, may God be pleased with him, who said: The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: “There is none among
you
but that God will speak to him on the Day of Resurrection,
without any interpreter between him and God.
Then he will look and see nothing before him. Then he will look again and see the
Fire before him. So whoever among you can protect himself from the Fire, even with a date, let him do so.” This hadith was narrated by Ibn Hatim, may God be pleased with him. [Music] This proves the
attribute of speech for God Almighty
and clarifies the virtue of charity, showing that it is a means of protection from the Fire. [
Music] It also indicates
that no deed should be belittled, even if it is small.
[Music] Another
narration mentions that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: “Protect yourselves from the Fire.” Then he turned away and
averted his gaze. Then he said: “Protect yourselves from the Fire.” Then he turned away and
averted his gaze three times
until  We thought he was looking at her, then he said, "Protect yourselves from the
Fire, even with half a date. If you cannot find even that, then with a kind word." The
Imam, may God have mercy on him, narrated a
hadith of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.
[music]
This also contains the virtue of charity, even if it is only half a date, and the virtue of kind
words. A kind word is anything that
indicates guidance, warns against
rejection, brings about
reconciliation between people, or other good words. [music] A
gate through which 7,000 will enter Paradise without reckoning. And
in it is the hadith of Ibn Abbas, who said, "The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, '
The nations were shown to me.' Then a prophet would pass by with a nation, then a
prophet would pass by with a group, then a prophet would
pass by with ten, then a prophet would pass by with five, and then a
prophet would pass by alone."
Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with them both,
said, "The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, will pass by with another group." [music] This shows that the important thing is the truth, conforming to the truth, not the number. He said, "So I looked, and there was a great multitude. I said, 'O Gabriel, are
these my nation?' He said, 'No, but look at the horizon.' So
I looked, and there was a great multitude. He said, 'These are your nation, peace and blessings be upon
him.'" [
music]
And these 700 are ahead of them, with no reckoning or punishment.
[music]
This is a hadith about them.  And the speech, and God increased us
with every thousand,
mentioning among their attributes that they do not write, nor do they seek incantations, nor do they believe in omens, and they
rely on their Lord. We mentioned these
attributes previously.
And some
branding,
and they use
things,
and all this does
n't
[music].
He knew English, so '
Ukasha ibn Mihsan stood up and
said, "Pray to God that He makes me one of them." This shows the Companions' eagerness to follow him. So he said, "O God, make him one of them."
Then
another man stood up and said, "Pray to God that He makes me one of them." He said, "Ukasha has
preceded you in this." May God bless him and grant him peace.
This has a special virtue for 'Ukasha ibn Mihsan and a
testimony for him of Paradise, may God bless him and grant him peace. And
he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said, "A group from my nation will enter Paradise," meaning a
group of 70,000. May
God have mercy on Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with
him. May
God bless him and grant him peace.
Their faces will shine like the moon on the night of the full moon, indicating the
radiance of their faces due to their faith and obedience. And
Abu Hurairah said, "Then 'Ukasha ibn Mihsan stood up."  The lion
raised his cloak and said, "O Messenger of Allah, pray to
Allah that He makes me one of them." He meant a cloak he
raised. O Messenger of Allah, pray to Allah that He makes him one of them. He said, "O Allah,
make him one of them." Then a man from
the Ansar stood up and said, "O Messenger of Allah, pray to Allah that He makes me one of
them." He said, "Akasha has preceded you in this."
[Music]
Mention of the hadith of Sahl ibn Sa'd, may
Allah be pleased with him, who said, "The Prophet, may Allah be pleased with him, said, '
Seven thousand or seven hundred thousand of my nation will enter Paradise.' There is doubt
about one of them, may
Allah have mercy on him. Sahl ibn Sa'd, may Allah be pleased with him, said, 'Seven thousand will enter Paradise.'"
[Music]
He said, "Holding fast," meaning that one of the characteristics of these seventy thousand is that they hold fast, one holding the other,
until the first and the last of them enter
Paradise, their
faces like the light of the moon on the Night of Decree. This
also mentions some of the characteristics of these seven thousand, holding fast,
entering together, their faces like the moon.
[Music] And
he mentioned the hadith of Ibn Umar on the authority of the Prophet, may Allah be pleased with him, who
said, "The people of Paradise will enter Paradise and the people of Hell will enter Hell.
Then a caller will stand between them, '
O people of Hell, there is no death!' and 'O people of Paradise...'"  There is no death, the
eternal life of
the Imam, may God have mercy on him,
Ibn Umar, may God be pleased with them both, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said: The people of Paradise will enter Hellfire, then they will get up and say, "There is no death for you." And
this is another: that death will be brought in the form of a ram and
slaughtered between Paradise and Hellfire.
[Music]
Eternity without death, so they will increase their torment upon torment. And O
people of Paradise, eternity without death, so they will increase their bliss upon bliss. And it will be
called out to the inhabitants of Paradise and it will be
said to the inhabitants of Hellfire
that you are going to there is no death for you, so therefore your torment will increase. And it will be said
to the people of Paradise. And
similar to this is the hadith of Abu Hurairah, also the
hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him,
he said: Chapter on the description of Paradise and Hellfire. And Abu Saeed
said: The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: The first food that
the people of Paradise will eat is the extra liver of a whale. The
Imam, may God have mercy on him, may God bless him and grant him peace,
then explained the meaning of the Garden of Eden. Eden, what does it mean? He said:
Eternity. I lived in a land where I resided, and from it comes the mine, in a seat of
truth.  Yes, in the origin of truth
[music]
Fati and
he mentioned the hadith of
Imran on the authority of the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, who said:
I looked into Paradise and saw that most of its inhabitants were the poor. I
looked into Hell and saw that most of its inhabitants were women.
This hadith was previously mentioned
[music]
God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
mentioned the hadith of Usama on the authority of the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, who
said: I stood at the gate of Paradise and most of those who entered it were the poor, while the wealthy were
detained. The wealthy,
meaning the rich, were delayed. Detained,
meaning they were delayed in entering
Hell. They entered Paradise, but the inhabitants of Hell had already been ordered
to Hell. I stood at the gate of Hell and saw that
most of those who entered it were women. May God have
mercy on Usama, may God bless him and grant him peace. And
their delay here is the rich, in order to be held accountable for
their wealth and what they did at the place of judgment and at
the bridge. He said: The
Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said:
When the people of Paradise go to Paradise and the people of Hell go to Hell, death will be brought and placed
between Paradise and Hell,
then it will be slaughtered. Then a caller will call out: O people of Paradise, there is
no death! O people of Hell, there is no death! The
people of Paradise will increase in joy, and the
people of Hell will increase in joy.  We grieve for their grief, and this is what
Imam Ibn
Umar, may God be pleased with him, said, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said when the people of
Paradise have entered Paradise, the people of Hell have entered Hell.
Death
will be bought and placed between Paradise and Hell,
and then it will be slaughtered and made. The people of Paradise will have no more death, and the people of Hell will have no more death,
so the people of
Paradise will have happiness.
[Music]
Mention of the hadith of Abu Saeed al-Khudri, who said: The Messenger of
God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: God, Blessed and Exalted is He, says to
the people of Paradise: O people of Paradise.
They say: At Your service, our Lord, and at Your pleasure. He says: Are
you pleased? They say: Why should we not be pleased? You have given us
what You have not given to any of Your creation. He says: I will
give you something better than that. They say: O Lord, what is
better than that? He says: I will bestow My pleasure upon you, and I will never be
displeased with you after that.
Imam Abu Saeed al-Khudri, may God be pleased with him, may
God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
God will say: I will give you
something better than that.
[Music]
This contains proof of the attribute of speech for God, the Exalted, the
Almighty, and proof of God's mercy and favor upon the
believers in this world and the Hereafter.
God, the Almighty, the Majestic, and
among the greatest blessings that God gives to the people of
Paradise is that His pleasure descends upon them and never falls upon them, and that they
see His face. This is the greatest
blessing.
God, the Exalted, the Majestic, the Majestic, and He
mentioned the hadith of Anas, who said: Haritha was wounded on the day of Badr while he was a
boy. So his
mother came to the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, and
said: O Messenger of God, I know Haritha's place with
me
in Paradise. Be patient and seek reward from God. And if the
other happens, you will see what I will do. He said: Woe to you! Have
you gone mad? Meaning, have you lost your mind? Is there only
one Paradise? There are many Paradises, and he is
in the highest Paradise. And he is blessed with God's mercy. The hadith of Anas, may God be pleased with him, and [Music] God, peace and blessings be upon him. [Music] This contains the testimony for Haritha ibn Suraqa al-Ansari of Paradise, and that he is in the highest Paradise. Haritha ibn Suraqa, and
it also contains proof that  Paradise is abundant, and
among the best and highest of them is the Paradise of Al-Firdaws, whose
roof is the Throne of
God Almighty. And
he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, on the authority of the
Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, who said: “The distance between
the shoulders of the disbeliever is a
journey of three days for a swift rider.” May God Almighty have mercy on
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, may
God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music] And
Muslim added in his narration: “And the thickness of his skin is a
journey of three days.”
[Music] And
the greatness of the disbeliever’s creation in Hell is the reason for the greatness
of his punishment and the multiplication of his pain. So the greater
the body, the more severe the punishment and the wider the torment
upon him. And
the reason for the magnitude of the creation and the size of the disbeliever is that the
punishment can be more. And
this is also on the description of Hell and the greatness of its creation.
[Music] And it was
mentioned in the hadith that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, and
his companions heard a loud noise, meaning the falling of
something.
He said: “Do you know what this is?”  This stone was thrown into the
fire 70 years ago, and now it has reached its bottom. May
God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
Sahl ibn Sa'd, the
Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: "In
Paradise there is a tree under whose
shade a rider could travel for 100 years
without crossing it." Sahl ibn Sa'd, may
God be pleased with him. May God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music] It is mentioned
in the narration of the hadith of Abu Hurairah that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said: "Read, if you wish, 'And a shade extended.'"
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him. May God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
This also indicates the greatness of Paradise, its creation, its vastness, and
that it has levels.
So, if the people of Paradise see the
inhabitants of the high chambers and mansions as we see and
look
in this world at the bright, distant star in the sky, then how will people be able to see it? And similar to this is the
hadith of Abu Sa'id on the authority of the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, who
said: "In Paradise there is a tree under whose shade a
rider on a well-trained horse—meaning one that has become weak but is now
fast—could travel for
100 years without crossing it." This also indicates the vastness of
Paradise, like the hadith.  The previous Imam, Abu
Saeed, may God be pleased with him, may
God bless him and grant him peace,
100, and
he mentioned the hadith of Sahl bint, and it has been mentioned that
7,000 of my nation will go to Paradise, and so on. It has been mentioned with us
previously,
Saad, may God be pleased with him,
[music], may God bless him and grant him peace.
Likewise, the hadith of Sahl that we mentioned earlier, which is that the
people of Paradise will see the chambers in Paradise
as you see the stars in the sky, may
God bless him and grant him peace. And Saeed
also mentioned the
hadith of Abu Saeed, and he said, and he added to it, as you see, as you
see the
setting stars on the horizon, meaning like the stars going
east and west, and it is similar to what was mentioned previously. And
he mentioned the hadith of Anas
that the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, says to the people of
Hell, "If you had everything on earth, would you ransom yourself with it?"
to the end of the hadith.
God is the Greatest. And
this has also been mentioned previously.
God is the Greatest.
God is the Greatest. God is the Greatest. I bear witness
that there is no god but God. I bear witness that there is no god but God. I bear witness
that Muhammad is the Messenger of God. I bear
witness that Muhammad is the Messenger of God. Come
to prayer. Come to prayer. Come to success. Come to success.
God is the Greatest. God is the Greatest. There is
no god but God.
We said that this hadith of Anas has also been mentioned previously. The
hadith of Anas, may God be pleased with him, will be recited
after the prayer, God willing. God knows best. May God bless him and grant him peace.